une deux aimants voici un système
qui permette aux personnes amputées par
exemple de retrouver le plaisir du vélo
en glissant sur le côté le pied se
décrochent naturellement et va permettre
chez une personne à mobilité réduite de
pouvoir en cas d'arrêt brusque ou alors
en cas d'arrêt simple pour aller
chercher son pain à descendre du vélo
par exemple on a un mouvement qui est
facilitée pour ces personnes le projet a
germé il ya quatre ans à montbéliard et
après des récompenses en bataille
jusqu'à la finale nationale du concours
talents des cités
voilà julien patron à 26 ans patron
c'est un bien grand mot on est marin on
est on est qu une petite structure
aujourd'hui j'espère que ces structures
grandir à demain mais effectivement on
est sur une tranche d'âge où on a le
temps on n'a pas de famille on n'a pas
d'enfants à la maison à regarder
donc ça nous laisse un peu d'un peu de
temps pour développer là dessus prendre
quelques risques également un d'un point
de vue financier
donc je pense que c'est là la période
pour le faire très honnêtement si
j'avais 20 ans de plus elle ne porte pas
que j'aurais fait vingt ans de plus
massoud n'est pas loin de les avoir mais
il n'hésite pas lui non plus à prendre
des risques
ancien technicien de laboratoire il a
quitté l'iran pour besançon avec sa
famille sans parler un mot de français
sa deuxième fille aînée en franche comté
mais potée de fait ils ont elles ont à
l'école français et c'est ma femme ans
et travaille en acier toshack lausanne
et avoir un beau gosse en iran mais
c'est en france que massoud compte créer
son entreprise
avec cette étrange carré gris il tient
peut être son avenir entre les mains
massoud est l'inventeur d'un prototype
permettant de faciliter les analyse
microscopique rien déjà que le premier
contact y avait déjà une étincelle au
niveau des yeux de de massoud qui a fait
que voilà que j'y croyais vraiment à son
projet était lui en tout cas il n'y
croit c'est vraiment intéressant pour
moi c'est vraiment motivant parce que
j'étais technicien de lavaux dan ellis
microscopique pour dix ans je peux
continuer en septembre
massoud tout comme julien saurons ce
jeudi s'ils feront partie des six
vainqueurs définitifs du concours
talents des cités mais une victoire
comme une défaite ne changera rien à
leur envie d'entreprendre ni on l'espère
à leur réussite